What do you think, David?
>> So what I did,
is I looked across the rows and
tried to see which features
all three birds had in common.
They all lay eggs, so
I'm going to figure that birds law eggs.
They all have wings, so I' going to
figure that birds have wings.
And none of them have fur, so
I'm going to figure that
birds don't have fur.
Whether or
not they have talons can actually vary.
So the eagle and bluebird have
talons but the penguin does not.
And whether or
not they are large can vary.
The eagle and penguin are large,
but the bluebird's not.
So those things don't necessarily
define what a bird is.
But these three things
seem to me like they do.
>> That's a good answer, David.
But I should quickly note that
this idea that we can decide on
the features that should go into
a super class, given the features
that are shared among these subclasses,
works only for certain kind of concept.
It doesn't work for all concepts.
Particularly, it work for
concepts that have a formal nature,
as we will see in just a minute.